>> Jason: MATS, STAY SAFE,
JOINING ME NOW TO RESPOND IN
SOUTH CAROLINA,
SENATOR TIM SCOTT.
WE SAW THIS IN 2016, WE ARE
STILL MORE THAN A YEAR AWAY THAN
THE ELECTION.
IT SEEMS TO BE GETTING MORE
VIOLENT.
IS THERE ANYTHING TO BE DONE TO
QUELL THE NEGATIVITY IN TERMS OF
TURNING TO VIOLENCE?
PEOPLE CAN PROTEST, THAT'S THE
AMERICAN WAY.
BUT TO TURN TO VIOLENCE AND BE
ABLE TO ATTACK POLICE OFFICERS
SEEMS LIKE A BRIDGE TOO FAR.
>> IT'S JUST A BRIDGE TOO FAR,
IT'S THE MOST RIDICULOUS THING I
SAW ON TV TODAY.
I'M SO    SAID THAT, THINKING TA
I'M SO    SAID THAT, THINKING TT
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS ARE
FROM CHARLESTON TO AIKEN, FOR
THEIR SERVICE AND I KEEP TELLING
THE OFFICERS, IT'S NEVER BEEN
THIS HARD AND THEY SHAKE THEIR
HEAD.
WATCHING THIS SITUATION IN
MINNESOTA, IT JUST SICKENS MY
STOMACH.
WE HAVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO ARE
WILLING TO PUT THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE TO PROTECT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC AND YOU HAVE ANTI-TRUMP
PROTESTERS INSTIGATING AND
INCITING VIOLENCE AGAINST THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
HERE ARE FOLKS WHO SAY THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP SHOULD IT COME
DOWN AND THEY ARE INCITING
AND INSTIGATING VIOLENCE
AGAINST OUR LAW INFORMANTS MEANT
AND
AND FELLOW INFORMANTS.
>> Jason: WHO WANTS TO YOU THE
AVERAGE PERSON WHO HAS THEIR
RIGHT TO EXPRESS THEIR
FIRST AMENDMENT'S, BUT GETS
INTIMIDATED PHYSICALLY BY PEOPLE
LIKE THIS?
>> ABSOLUTELY COME I'VE HEARD
FROM FOLKS AND AIRPORTS TO
PUBLIC RALLIES WHO HAVE A MAGA
HATS ON, GUY TELLING ME AS AN
AFRICAN-AMERICAN FELLA, HE'S
BEEN ACCOSTED IN NEW YORK.
I READ THAT STORY AND ONE PERSON
CALL ME ABOUT ANOTHER INCIDENT.
THE TRUTH IS, YOU FIND PEOPLE
CONSISTENTLY BEING INTIMIDATED
AND THEN ASKING HIM TO COWER
DOWN AND BOW DOWN TO THE NEW
SOCIALIST REGIME.
THE APPROACH TOWARDS AN AGREE,
GETTING TO RUN AMOK.
WE CANNOT AFFORD THAT THERE IS
DEMOCRACY ON EARTH AND WHAT YOU
SEE OUTSIDE THIS RALLY AND IN
THIS COUNTRY IS THIS LEVEL THE
ANGER AND HOSTILITY TOWARDS THE
PRESIDENT AND FRANKLY TOWARDS
FOLKS WHO WANT TO DO IT BY THE
BOOK.
FOLKS WHO WANT TO OBEY THE LAW.
FOLKS WHO WANT TO DRAIN THE
SWAMP.
AS OUR GOOD AMERICANS,
HARDWORKING AMERICANS WERE JUST
LOOKING FORWARD TO BEING
INVOLVED IN THE CIVIL ENGAGEMENT
THAT IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT THE
FREEDOM OF THE FOLKS ON THE
OTHER SIDE SO THAT THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT, THE RIGHT TO PROTEST.
BUT NOT THE RIGHT TO INCITE
VIOLENCE.
NOT THE RIGHT TO INSTIGATE A
PHYSICAL RESPONSE.
THIS WAS A SICKENING SCENE THAT
WE SAW OUTSIDE OF THE TRUMP
RALLY.
>> Jason: FOR THOSE OF YOU
JUST JOINING US, THE PRESIDENT
WAS AT A CAMPAIGN RALLY THERE IN
MINNEAPOLIS, VICE PRESIDENT
SPOKE, ERIC TRUMP SPOKE, THEY
HAD A DISCUSSION WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND THEN CAMPAIGN
RALLY.
HOUR AND 40 MINUTES, IT'S
WRAPPING UP, BUT HAPPEN IT'S
HARD TO TURN VIOLENCE, POLICE
OFFICERS GETTING THROWN OUT, AND
AT LEAST ONE ON FIRE ACCORDING
TO A REPORTER, CONCERN FOR THE
SAFETY OF THOSE LEAVING.
BUT ROUGHLY 19 OR 20,000 PEOPLE
LEAVING AND TRYING TO GET HOME.
THERE IS HELP WITH THE SKY
BRIDGE GOING ACROSS, THERE'S A
MASSIVE DIRECT CONFRONTATION
BETWEEN THE TRUMP SUPPORTERS
WERE AT THE RALLY AND THESE
PEOPLE THAT WERE NOT JUST
PROTESTING BUT ACTUALLY WANTING
TO RIOT.
THEY WERE THEN ABLE TO GO INTO
THIS PARKING LOT BUT OUR OWN
MATT HAS TOLD US IT WOULD NOT,
PEOPLE LIKE ANTIFA AND SOME
OTHER PEOPLE THAT WERE REALLY
TRYING TO INCITE VIOLENCE AND
THROWING THINGS AT HORSES, AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
IN SENATOR, AS I LOOK AT THIS
ELECTION, FIRST OF ALL, IT'S
STILL A YEAR AWAY, BUT AS I LOOK
AT THIS, THERE'S A DISTINCTION
AND I'M NOT TRYING TO POLITICIZE
THIS, BUT IT'S A BIG MESSAGE OF
ONE DONALD TRUMP A SAINT, IT'S
VERY PRO-LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BUT WITH THIS RALLY AND
MINNEAPOLIS, GOT THE REDSHIRTS,
SUPPORTING TRUMP AT THERE'S A
BIG ISSUE THERE WITH THE MAYOR.
WHEN YOU HEARD WHAT THE MAYOR
WAS TRYING TO DO TO SHUT DOWN
THE DISCUSSION, WHAT WAS YOUR
REACTION?
>> IT SOUNDS LIKE PRICE GOUGING,
NUMBER ONE, FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
HAVING WORKED THROUGH AND LIVED
THROUGH HURRICANES ON THE COAST.
YOU SEE FOLKS RAISING THE PRICES
TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
SITUATION.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE MAYOR, THE
PUBLIC SERVICE, WAS TRYING TO
PRICE GOUGE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN